Is it okay to just use a cell phone
camera to record video of your users?
Is there any minimum
required video product?
>> Honestly, the minimum required video
product is a flip phone from the 90s.
>> Okay.
>> Right,
recording video is
the most important thing.
As long as you have some kind of video,
from some angle, somewhere, it works.
Ideally you have a cell phone, a cell
phone video is fine, laptop is fine.
If you have a professional camera,
feel free to bring it.
But actually sometimes bringing
a professional camera Is too much.
>> Right.
>> You don't need that quality,
that high quality video, right?
You're not making an Apple promo video.
All you need is enough to put up
on a conference room screen for
somebody else to see, either a VC or
a PM or your engineers.
>> Right.
>> Or even other designers.
Right, because humans are really good
at figuring out the emotional import of
video, even if it's grainy and low res.
>> Yeah, and if you do bring
a big professional camera,
it might make your test subjects
feel a little bit intimidated.
You don't need to bring lights, you
don't need to bring a boom microphone or
anything like that.
Just have a little cell phone camera,
prop it up on something.
You can get one of those twisty
tripods to stick your camera on.
There are other little tiny flip cams,
little video cameras,
with actual quarter inch holes in
the bottom to stick onto tripods.
Those work great too, but
the main goal is keep it informal so
the people don't feel insinuated,
but just collect some kind of video.
>> Right.
>> One thing to note is that audio is
also really important.
And so, cell phones generally do a
pretty good job of recording audio, but
it's worth checking the audio to
make sure that you can understand
what the people are saying.
Again, you don't need a boom mic,
you don't need to mic the person, but
it's really useful to make
sure that you can hear them.
One thing you can actually
do is buy a separate,
higher quality audio recorder which
tend to be fairly small and unobtrusive.
Hit record, put it on the table,
leave it there running, clap or
something in the video to sync
up the audio and the video.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And then just leave the audio out of
the video recorder, and
use the audio from the table recorder.
>> Right.
>> Which tends to be much better.
>> Awesome, thank you.